merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission je suis désolé qu'on rallonge
le temps mais nous on n'avait rien
demandé donc on aurait pu gagner du
temps si on n'est pas ouvert ce débat
qui est quand même un vrai sujet madame
la ministre pardonnez-moi avec l'amitié
que j'ai pour vous on va pas vous
décrire ce qu'est la ruralité
vous en êtes encore si je filais si vous
êtes encore ministre bon on a un sujet
très simple est-ce qu'on peut se parler
en français
y compris au Comité des finances locales
une dotation de solidarité rurale c'est
une dotation de solidarité rurale la
ruralité se caractérise par un habitat
dispersé très étendu parce qu'il y a des
fermes et donc pour rejoindre la ferme
au bourg il y a des routes et que les
routes sont extrêmement modernes puisque
maintenant on met des unités de
méthanisation dans les exploitations
agricoles il y a des camions qui doivent
circuler il y a un seul critère sur la
dotation de
qui est vraiment rurale c'est la
longueur de voirie plus vous êtes petit
plus vous avez de la longueur de voirie
il n'y a aucune subvention sur la voirie
alors qu'on vienne bricoler un truc pour
y remettre des habitants et de la
densité c'est venir introduire ce que
j'appelle un vice caché dans une
dotation qui est clairement ciblée et
claire et que mes collègues l'ont dit
aujourd'hui la voirie elle dépend de la
déclaration des élus ruraux mais madame
la ministre ils sont allés à l'école les
mers euros ils savent mesurer une
longueur de voirie et si
l'administration n'a pas confiance elle
envoie un contrôleur
alors en plus vous avez inventé un
critère extrêmement compliqué ça ne va
pas quant aux communes qui aurait confié
la voirie au métropole je répète plus
désagréable que je ne l'était mais les
métropoles ont des dotations largement
supérieures aux communautés de communes
et qu'il convienne conviendrait de
rééquilibrer donc moi je pense que c'est
tellement flou qu'il y a plusieurs loups
dans cette affaire et qu'on gagnerait à
rester là où on en était merci merci
chers collègues madame
[Musique]